le bonheur d'être rassemblés quelles que
soient nos différences nos démarches
différentes pour atteindre un même but
l'indépendance de la france et une
europe des coopérations et aujourd'hui
c'est un grand jour on a rêvé de ce jour
et on allait chacun le fêter séparément
dans notre petite chapelle parce qu'on
n'est pas tout à fait d'accord sur la
méthode sur l'objet comment on atteint
l'objectif
donc c'est simplement le bonheur d'être
ensemble et la présence d'une union
futur ça présage du fait que le bric
sites comme il va réussir pour la grande
bretagne parce que la liberté paye
toujours plus que la servitude
je pense que les français vont évoluer
et donc obligatoirement que les forces
politiques qui veulent l'indépendance de
la france avec des nuances
d'organisations européennes vont pouvoir
peut-être travailler davantage ensemble
et les français l'attendent